[Music]
the world is at war but it didn't begin
with a battle
it began with hope I snuck him out of
the lab to save his life
oh he's a smart one with me what are you
gonna name Caesar humans believed they
could control nature we gave Caesar to
therapy that allows the brain to repair
its cure to Alzheimer's Oh Caesar
continues to show cognitive skills that
far exceed that of a human counterpart
this is wrong well it works some things
on men to be changed what was thought to
be a miracle cure it's been a
complication
created a virus that made humans weaker
and ace smarter than our people you know
they justthinking borrow me the Apes
look to Caesar to leave them
the simian virus spread millions of
humans died it was a virus created by
scientists in a lab it can't blame the
Apes some believed they could exist
together we both have families you want
to protect yours I want to protect mine
it's our only chance for peace others
believed only one civilization could
survive you won't wear your poison what
a cube is it on humans more than Apes if
you threaten this family you will
retaliate stop sure what are you doing
sorry friend
war has begun
the world fell into further chaos now
the fate of the planet will finally be
decided we are not savages
they fight only to survive we created
them now we will bring it in to their
kind
I do not start this war what I will
oh yes child I don't know but she was
you
he has no one else we are not savages
apes fight only to survive
bad human kill eight all dead now a long
time Oh bad humans
soldier
[Music]
years from now your children will ask
you what did you do in the greatest war
and you can tell them I fought to
protect this world we've created them
but now
[Music]
we will bring it in to their car
no mercy no peace this this war
beeps together sleep
you are impressive smart as hell
you're stronger than we are but you're
taking this all much too personally so
emotional
does not starve this more
but I will finish it
[Music]